l'actualité d'abord avec je vous le
disais dans les titres un campus vert
recherche et développement dans le
milieu automobile qui va se développer à
poissy c'est le groupe sts est l'anti ce
qu'il a annoncé le 27 octobre dernier
bon jour mais les nippes hockey de la
rédaction de tv soit 118 et c'est un
nouveau site qui renforce l'implantation
du monde automobile dans les yvelines eh
oui soixante mille mètres carrés
réunissant la recherche et le
développement mais aussi les activités
tertiaires ce campus entièrement
végétalisée situer donc à poisy
rassemblera en 2024 une partie des
équipes r&d pour le moment basé à vélizy
et l'ensemble des salariés regroupés à
poissy et attrapes ce site ne sera pas
le seul de ce talent tice dans les
yvelines en sera le plus important avec
plus de 11000 personnes attendues le
groupe stèle en tice est né de la fusion
du groupe psa et de fiat chrysler
automobile mais ce n'est pas le seul
groupe à développer et installer à des
sites r&d dans le département renault
vise l'économie circulaire sur son site
de flins sur seine oui à l'horizon 2024
il n'y aura plus de production de
voitures pour le site de renault flins
qui fabrique actuellement la zoé la
voiture électrique en mars 2021 le
groupe présentait le programme station
flins le centre d'innovation de
l'économie régénératrice de la
refactorisation son objectif le
reconditionnement des véhicules
d'occasion la valorisation des pièces
usagées de nouvelles activités liées au
recyclage et la transition bas carbone
de la mobilité renault vise un bilan
carbone négatif à devenir d'ici 2030
avec un lien décidément aussi dans les
yvelines puisque le groupe est
historiquement implanté dans le
département et oui depuis 1998 renault à
son technocentre à guyancourt c'est le
premier centre de recherche et de
développement automobile en europe sur
150 hectares de terrain les équipes
pensent les programmes des gammes
renault bien sûr mais aussi dacia et
renault sous ce sont plus de dix mille
salariés qui sont présents sur le centre
merci mélanie pour toutes ces précisions
et on aura l'occasion de donner la
parole aux acteurs indirectement de ce
nouveau dossier qui a été annoncé un ce
campus vert recherche et développement
qui a va voir le jour sur le site de
poissy